hey everyone its Sandra Turner sorry
n.com
and in this video I'm going to be going
over the plantar reflex what I'm going
to do for you is I'm going to go over
the basics about this reflex and then
I'm going to demonstrate for you on a
person what a positive and negative
plantar reflex looks like with the
Babinski sign so first let's talk about
what the plantar reflex is this is a
superficial reflex found on the bottom
of the foot now this is different than
the deep tendon reflexes that we covered
in the previous videos in that these
reflexes are due to the receptors found
on the skin and what we do is we elicit
a reflex through the skin rather than
the muscle like how you do in the deep
tendons now whenever you can do a
plantar reflex you're looking for the
Babinski sign and the Babinski sign
which you'll see here in a minute you'll
see a positive and a negative one and
whenever you see a positive Babinski
sign this is this is abnormal you will
see dorsal dorsiflexion of the big toes
and fanning of the toes so in other
words you're gonna see the big tone the
toes dorsiflex which means they're going
to move out like that and this is common
now this is a normal sign if you are
doing this on an infant less than 24
months of age but if you're not it can
be indicated of an upper motor neuron
disease now it's a negative of insky
sign which is normal you want to see
this in someone 24 months or older it's
where you have plantar flexion and
curling of the toes with a flexion of
the forefoot so you'll see the toes sort
of plantar flex and and curl so now let
me demonstrate for you what that looks
like okay for the plantar reflex we're
taking l4 to s2 and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna lightly stroke up the
lateral side of the sole of the foot
inward through the ball of the foot to
make like an upside-down jay and what
we're watching for we're gonna look at
the toes and we want for a normal
response for it to plantar flex and for
the toes to curl inward positive
Babinski sign would be whatever
the foot dorsiflex and the big toe fans
out so let's see what we get
ok and that was plantar flexion notice
that the toes they curled inward let's
do it again and they curled inwards so
this is normal okay let's see what a
positive Babinski sign looks like and
notice we had dorsiflexion of the foot
and the toe stand out let's do it again
okay so that is how you check the
plantar reflex be sure to check out my
other reflex examination videos and
thank you so much for watching and
please consider subscribing to this
YouTube channel